Vous connaissez Tim Ferriss ?
C’est un peu l’expert en productivité
de la Silicon Valley.
Son obsession,
c’est de tester plein de méthodes
et de techniques ;
de trouver les plus efficaces,
et de s’en servir pour obtenir des résultats
exceptionnels,
plus vite
et plus facilement.
Or,
il a dit une chose très importante :
« Complexity fails. »,
que je traduis par
« La complexité mène à l’échec. ».
C’est vrai
QUOI que vous fassiez.
C’est encore plus vrai
si vous faites quelque chose de difficile,
comme…
une dissertation.
Dans cette vidéo,
je vais commenter
une dissertation de culture générale
qui a été notée 15 sur 20
au concours d’entrée de l’ENM,
l’École Nationale de la Magistrature,
en 2019.
Si vous voulez avoir
de BONNES bases de méthodologie
pour comprendre mon commentaire de cette copie,
je vous conseille de vous inscrire
à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation.
Le lien doit s’afficher maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
et vous pouvez aussi le trouver
dans la description.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc vous pouvez regarder cette vidéo en
entier,
et puis vous découvrirez ma méthodologie
après,
ou un autre jour.
Vous pouvez également
TÉLÉCHARGER la copie :
le lien est dans la description.
J’en profite pour remercier Arthur,
dont c’est la copie.
Il m’a autorisé non seulement à l’utiliser,
mais aussi à la commenter
dans le détail en vidéo.
Donc si tu regardes cette vidéo Arthur :
merci,
c’est vraiment sympa.
Alors,
Arthur a présenté le concours de l’ENM,
l’École Nationale de la Magistrature,
comme je l’ai déjà dit.
La particularité de ce concours,
c’est que c’est un concours
de la fonction publique.
Dans ce concours,
l’épreuve de dissertation de culture générale
s’appelle plus précisément
« Connaissance et compréhension
du monde contemporain ».
Depuis 2009,
les sujets sont plus orientés vers les questions
contemporaines
pour améliorer l’égalité des chances,
MAIS les sujets sont toujours à inscrire
dans une histoire LONGUE
— donc c’est toujours de la culture générale,
cette épreuve.
Les énoncés précisent que c’est
« une composition portant
sur une question posée aujourd’hui à la
société française
dans ses dimensions judiciaires,
juridiques,
sociales,
politiques,
historiques,
économiques,
philosophiques
et culturelles »
Ouh là :
ça fait peur !
En plus,
c’est une épreuve de CINQ heures !
Les candidats ont intérêt
à être préparés !
Ce concours,
je le connais bien,
parce que j’ai moi-même préparé
des concours de la fonction publique
pendant deux ans ;
et puis surtout,
chaque année,
je prépare à ce concours
des élèves inscrits à ma formation
à la méthodologie de la dissertation.
Donc je connais bien
les attendus de l’épreuve,
l’état d’esprit,
ce qu’il faut faire,
et ce qu’il faut éviter.
Le sujet de 2019,
c’était « la démocratie ».
Alors,
il peut paraître difficile,
parce que ce n’est pas une question,
et que c’est vaste.
MAIS en même temps,
c’est un thème
VU
et REVU
par les candidats
— c’est même un chapitre
dans beaucoup de manuels.
Donc c’était en réalité
un sujet FACILE.
MAIS ce n’est jamais facile en réalité,
parce que les candidats sont évalués
LES UNS PAR RAPPORT AUX AUTRES !
En fait,
ce sont simplement LES ENJEUX
qui changent.
Sur un sujet comme celui-ci,
par exemple,
TOUS les candidats ont des choses à dire
— donc ce ne sont pas les connaissances
qui permettront de décrocher une bonne note.
Ça sera l’argumentation !
Et c’est là que je voulais en venir
en vous parlant de Tim Ferriss
au tout début de la vidéo :
bien argumenter,
c’est difficile,
donc vous devez ÉVITER
la complexité.
On va voir comment Arthur s’y est pris,
lui.
Cette vidéo est longue,
donc n’hésitez pas à la regarder
PARTIE
par partie.
Pour accéder à la partie qui vous intéresse,
servez-vous du minutage dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Allez, c’est parti.
Prenez de quoi noter.
Mettez votre téléphone en mode avion,
et concentrez-vous.
Je vais procéder comme un correcteur :
je commence par me faire
une PREMIÈRE IMPRESSION
globale
de la copie.
Alors,
voici la copie d’Arthur.
Je vais la regarder rapidement pour me faire
une première impression générale.
Il a noté le sujet de la dissertation, c’est
toujours utile.
Il met bien en évidence les références
en les soulignant.
La calligraphie n’est pas superbe, mais
ça semble lisible pour l’instant.
Je vois qu’il marque bien les alinéas,
ce qui permet de bien distinguer les paragraphes
— je ne sais pas si c’est moi qui lui
ai donné l’idée, comme j’insiste souvent
sur ce point, mais ce qu’il a fait, c’est
très bien pour le lecteur.
Alors, l’introduction est longue, voire
très longue : quasiment 2 pages et demi.
C’est souvent la marque des très bonnes
copies, mais là je vois quand même des paragraphes
indigestes.
Celui-ci, par exemple, prend les ¾ de la
page !
J’arrive à l’annonce de plan : OK.
Le plan est apparent : c’est la convention
pour la dissertation de culture générale
de l’ENM.
Arthur a choisi un plan type ENA en 4 parties
: grand I) A, B ; grand II) A, B.
Il annonce les sous-parties A et B.
Là je vois l’introduction partielle : c’est
bien, parce que je me dis déjà qu’il tient
le lecteur par la main, et donc que ma lecture
sera plus facile.
Je descends dans le I) A).
Les paragraphes sont toujours bien marqués
par des alinéas, et Arthur saute même une
ligne — ce n’est pas obligatoire, mais
c’est encore plus clair.
Les références sont toujours soulignées.
Petite conclusion partielle avant le grand
I) B.
C’est toujours aussi rigoureux dans la présentation.
Là, le 1er paragraphe est un peu long quand
même : je crois que je vais souffrir…
Conclusion partielle avant le grand II).
Et puis même présentation que pour le grand
I).
C’est toujours le même format, rien à
signaler.
J’arrive à la conclusion.
Elle a l’air de « faire le job », le paragraphe
est assez long.
La copie fait 12 pages : c’est plutôt long,
mais l’épreuve dure quand même 5 heures,
et les bonnes copies sont plus longues que
la moyenne.
Il faudra voir si la qualité est aussi au
rendez-vous.
Bon, voilà pour ma première impression.
Alors,
qu’est-ce que j’en pense ?
J’en pense
que la copie d’Arthur semble très sérieuse.
Visuellement,
elle est structurée très clairement
et bien aérée.
Grâce aux alinéas
et aux sauts de ligne,
je ne me perdrai jamais.
Le plan apparent va aussi
me faciliter la tâche.
Je ne vois que deux défauts :
la calligraphie n’est pas toujours top,
je vais peut-être avoir du mal à lire
à certains endroits ;
et le second défaut,
c’est que certains paragraphes
paraissent vraiment longs.
Ça,
ça me fait peur,
parce que c’est le mal de crâne assuré.
Bon,
c’est vrai que de toute façon,
les correcteurs ne lisent le développement
qu'en diagonale ;
mais MOI
je vais lire la copie en entier !
Ça va que c’est une dissertation
sur un sujet intéressant…
Bon,
en conclusion,
la copie d’Arthur produit une BONNE,
voire une TRÈS BONNE
première impression.
En tant que correcteur,
je me dis que c’est un travail très sérieux.
Je suis donc déjà sous l’emprise
d’un biais de confirmation POSITIF :
je situe DÉJÀ la copie
dans une fourchette de notes HAUTE.
Je sais que,
sauf accident,
je lui mettrai au minimum 12
ou 14
— voire plus, bien sûr,
si la qualité le justifie.
D’ailleurs,
le rapport du jury de l’épreuve
de cette même année
a souligné
l’IMPORTANCE de la présentation :
« On ne saurait trop rappeler aux candidats
l’importance du soin à apporter
à la présentation formelle des copies. »
On ne vous demande pas de faire du design,
MAIS le soin sera toujours récompensé.
Bon,
voilà pour ma première impression.
Ce que vous devez retenir,
c’est que,
comme Arthur,
vous pourrez séduire le correcteur,
et le prédisposer à vous donner une bonne
note,
en présentant
et en structurant TRÈS CLAIREMENT
votre dissertation.
Allez,
il est maintenant temps d’entrer dans le
dur.
Ce que font souvent les correcteurs,
c’est qu’ils commencent par lire
l’introduction et la conclusion
en tandem,
avant de regarder
le développement de la dissertation
en diagonale.
Donc je vais faire comme eux :
je vais d’abord commenter dans le détail
l’introduction,
puis la conclusion,
de la copie d’Arthur.
Allez,
c’est parti !
Ah, ça fait plaisir d’avoir affaire à
quelque chose de clair !
Ce 1er paragraphe, je sais qu’il est consacré
à l’accroche de la dissertation
— je n’ai pas besoin de me prendre la
tête.
Il comporte 3 phrases plutôt longues, ce
qui est satisfaisant.
Dans la 1ère phrase, Arthur introduit une
référence : un discours politique tenu lors
de la Révolution française.
« Dans son discours du 7 septembre 1789,
l’Abbé Sieyès laissait entendre que parler
de « démocratie représentative » est un
oxymore. »
Alors, si vous ne le savez pas, Sieyès c’est
un célèbre Révolutionnaire français.
Il est notamment connu pour 2 essais : son
Essai sur les privilèges et Qu'est-ce que
le Tiers-État ?, qui est devenu un texte
fondateur de la Révolution française.
Le discours du 7 septembre 89 que cite Arthur
est passé à la postérité comme une défense
du gouvernement représentatif. Ce que dit
Sieyès, c’est que les citoyens ne doivent
pas faire les lois eux-mêmes, mais déléguer
cette tâche à des représentants éclairés.
Autre petite précision : un OXYMORE, c’est
une figure de style qui consiste à allier
deux termes normalement incompatibles.
L’exemple qu’on donne tout le temps, c’est
« une obscure clarté ».
Alors, la référence est PERTINENTE, puisqu’elle
porte sur le concept de démocratie. Et sur
la forme, la phrase est très claire : on
saisit son sens instantanément.
Arthur explique dans la 2ème phrase de ce
paragraphe pourquoi Sieyès considère que
la démocratie représentative est un oxymore,
c’est-à-dire pourquoi les idées de démocratie
et de représentativité sont incompatibles.
Son explication n’est pas super claire :
« À son sens, seul le gouvernement peut
être représentatif, mais pas la démocratie
puisque, par définition, elle renvoie à
l’exercice du pouvoir, dans une société
donnée, par le peuple souverain. »
Quel est le problème sur le fond ?
Le problème, c’est que la phrase ne se
concentre pas sur l’idée essentielle.
Quelle est l’idée essentielle qui justifie
l’affirmation de Sieyès ?
Eh bien c’est que dans la démocratie, par
définition, le peuple souverain exerce LUI-MÊME,
c’est-à-dire de manière DIRECTE, le pouvoir.
Donc Arthur aurait pu expliquer cette idée
plus simplement.
Moi, j’écrirais :
« À son sens, seul le gouvernement peut
être représentatif, mais pas la démocratie,
puisqu’elle signifie par définition que
le peuple souverain exerce lui-même, c’est-à-dire
de manière directe, le pouvoir. »
Après, la phrase de la copie est plutôt
efficace. L’idée est connectée à la précédente
par un lien logique de précision (« À son
sens »). La phrase est bien structurée,
les virgules sont aux bons endroits. Je note
simplement que la locution « dans une société
donnée » est inutile.
Souvenez-vous que c’est important de concentrer
chaque phrase sur l’idée ESSENTIELLE que
vous souhaitez communiquer.
Alors, 3ème phrase de l’accroche :
« Deux cent trente années plus tard, le
débat sur la forme que la démocratie doit
prendre est toujours d’actualité ; directe,
représentative, mixte… la question est
à nouveau posée. »
Là, ce que fait Arthur, c’est de justifier
l’intérêt du sujet. Il dit au correcteur
: « c’est une bonne idée, ce sujet, parce
que c’est en effet un problème intéressant
— et nous avons donc intérêt à y réfléchir.
»
C’est exactement ce qu’il faut faire en
termes de méthodo : dans un 1er temps vous
captez l’attention du correcteur avec une
accroche pertinente, puis vous justifiez l’intérêt
du sujet.
Arthur le fait d’autant plus intelligemment
qu’il souligne que c’est une question
« d’actualité », qu’elle est « à
nouveau posée ».
Pourquoi c’est intelligent ?
Parce que c’est précisément l’enjeu
de la dissertation de culture générale du
concours d’entrée de l’ENM, qui s’intitule
en réalité « Connaissance et compréhension
du monde contemporain ».
L’énoncé lui-même indique que la dissertation
porte « sur une question posée
aujourd’hui à la société française ».
Donc en soulignant dès la fin de l’accroche
que la question est « toujours d’actualité
», qu’elle est « à nouveau posée », Arthur
montre qu’il connaît bien les règles du
jeu et qu’il s’apprête à faire TRÈS
PRÉCISÉMENT ce qu’on lui demande.
Là, il marque vraiment des points ; il renforce
le biais de confirmation positif créé par
la première impression produite par la copie.
En tant que correcteur, je me dis que c’est
un candidat sérieux, bien préparé.
Je reviens à la phrase elle-même :
« Deux cent trente années plus tard, le
débat sur la forme que la démocratie doit
prendre est toujours d’actualité ; directe,
représentative, mixte… la question est
à nouveau posée. »
1789 + 230 = 1789 + 200 + 30 = 1989 + 30 = … 2019
!
C’est un détail, mais cette précision
de calcul fait bonne impression.
Bon, que dit Arthur dans cette phrase ?
Il dit que la question dont traitait Sieyès
dans son discours — c’est l’accroche
de la dissertation — cette question n’est
toujours pas résolue aujourd’hui.
Sur la forme, maintenant, il n’y a rien
à signaler : la phrase est liée à la précédente
par un connecteur logique d’addition, et
elle est claire (plus que la précédente
d’ailleurs).
Seul petit bémol : il fallait plutôt énumérer
les formes de la démocratie (« directe,
représentative, mixte ») entre parenthèses
après le verbe « prendre ».
Et puis les trois petits points, ça fait
un peu journalistique — mais bon, ce sont
des détails, et puis ça crée tout de même
un peu de dynamisme.
Bon, voilà pour le paragraphe d’accroche.
À part peut-être la 2ème phrase, qui ne
cible pas assez l’idée qu’elle veut communiquer
— à part ce petit défaut, le paragraphe
est efficace.
Je passe au suivant.
« Classiquement, le mot « démocratie » est
d’origine grecque. Le « demos » signifiant
le peuple, le « kratos » renvoyant au pouvoir.
»
Là, Arthur définit le concept de démocratie
en partant de son étymologie en grec ancien
: le pouvoir, « kratos », appartient au
peuple, « demos ».
Il connecte les 2 racines grecques dans la
3ème phrase du paragraphe :
« La démocratie serait donc l’exercice
du pouvoir par le peuple. »
C’est bien, mais il aurait pu communiquer
l’idée plus efficacement.
Moi, j’écrirais simplement :
« À consulter son étymologie grecque, la
démocratie signifie l’exercice du pouvoir
(kratos) par le peuple (demos). »
Les 3 phrases d’Arthur sont plutôt efficaces
(notamment parce qu’elles sont courtes),
mais je relève plusieurs faiblesses : l’adverbe
« classiquement » est inutile ; Arthur a
déjà utilisé le verbe « renvoyer » — dont
le sens est, je trouve, trop vague — Arthur
a déjà utilisé ce verbe il y a quelques
phrases ; autre faiblesse, la 2ème phrase
ne comporte pas de verbe conjugué ; et enfin,
il faut utiliser des guillemets français
!
Apparemment, c’est tout pour la définition
des termes, parce qu’Arthur enchaîne avec
un peu d’histoire dans les 2 phrases suivantes
:
« L’idée de démocratie est apparue à
Athènes, entre le Ve siècle et le IVe siècle
avant Jésus-Christ. Elle ne date donc pas
de 1789 ; en revanche, c’est à partir de
cette année là qu’elle sera admise en
France. »
Dans les 3 phrases suivantes, il compare la
démocratie athénienne et l’idée de la
démocratie qui a émergé lors de la Révolution
française. Il dit que c’est peut-être
le facteur de la TAILLE de la société qui
explique la différence entre ces deux conceptions
: il y avait seulement 40 000 citoyens à
Athènes, tandis qu’il y en avait environ
28 millions en France à l’époque de Sieyès.
Dans les 3 phrases qui suivent celles-ci,
Arthur passe sur le plan des idées, où il
oppose Sieyès, l’auteur de son accroche,
à Rousseau.
Enfin, dans la dernière phrase de ce paragraphe,
il justifie À NOUVEAU le sujet :
« C’est aussi celui qui oppose aujourd’hui
une partie de la population française, qui
ne se sent plus représentée. »
Bon voilà, j’ai dévoilé la structure
du paragraphe : Arthur définit la démocratie
à partir de l’étymologie ; il fait un
rappel historique ; il évoque le facteur
démographique pour expliquer la différence
entre les conceptions athénienne et française
; il oppose Sieyès et Rousseau ; et enfin
il rejustifie le sujet de la dissertation.
Vous voyez le problème ?
C’est beaucoup trop compliqué ! Il fait
5 CHOSES DIFFÉRENTES dans un MÊME paragraphe
!!
Là, il a dérapé en termes de méthodo.
Il a voulu faire compliqué parce qu’il
connaît bien son cours sur la démocratie,
mais il suffisait de faire une seule chose
: éclairer le sens du concept.
Moi, j’aurais d’abord évoqué l’étymologie
comme lui ; puis dans un second temps, j’aurais
opposé l’idée originelle de la démocratie
aux nombreuses et diverses déclinaisons pratiques
qui ont émergé dans l’histoire des sociétés.
Non seulement il a existé et il existe des
démocraties dans lesquelles le peuple n’exerce
PAS DIRECTEMENT le pouvoir, mais il y a aussi
des régimes qui n’ont de « démocratique
» que le nom. Par exemple, la Corée du Nord
s’appelle officiellement la « République
populaire et démocratique de Corée » !
Voici à quoi ressemblerait mon paragraphe
de définition des termes :
« À consulter son étymologie grecque, la
démocratie signifie l’exercice du pouvoir
(kratos) par le peuple (demos). Ce concept
a cependant inspiré diverses déclinaisons
concrètes. Si certaines, comme la démocratie
athénienne, semblent fidèles à l’idée
originelle, d’autres, comme la Cinquième
République française, n’apparaissent pas
comme des démocraties « chimiquement pures
». »
Je me serais contenté de ces 3 phrases.
Le problème, dans la dissertation d’Arthur,
c’est qu’il perd de vue l’ENJEU du paragraphe
: définir les termes du sujet.
Il s’agit juste d’éclairer, en quelques
phrases, le sens du concept de démocratie.
Bien sûr, il y a des choses intéressantes
dans ce qu’il a écrit — mais tout ça
a sa place dans le développement, où les
connaissances serviront à donner de la force
aux arguments. En dissertation, vous devez
dire des choses intéressantes AU BON ENDROIT.
Là, Arthur donne l’impression de réciter
son cours dès le 2ème paragraphe de l’introduction.
J’ajoute que comme il veut trop en faire,
la qualité du propos décroît au fur et
à mesure qu’on avance dans le paragraphe.
La définition du concept de démocratie par
l’étymologie est bonne ; le rappel historique
est juste ; la considération sur le facteur
démographique est pertinente.
MAIS ça devient moins bon lorsqu’il passe
sur le plan des idées.
1ère remarque : à quoi bon citer Rousseau
en une seule phrase juste après une considération
pratique ?
Sur le plan de la nature des connaissances
mobilisées, ça fait histoire - technique
- philosophie politique - logique : c’est
difficile à suivre pour le lecteur.
J’ajoute que l’idée de la démocratie
représentative n’a pas émergé dans Du
contrat social. Rousseau y dit simplement
qu’on peut admettre ce système dans de
grands ensembles (comme la France) si on l’encadre
strictement.
En réalité, c’est difficile de dater la
naissance d’une idée, mais celle de la
démocratie représentative semble remonter
aux débats qui ont accompagné les révolutions
anglaises au XVIIe siècle — elle est en
fait antérieure au bouquin de Rousseau.
Donc avec cette seule phrase, Arthur complique
la lecture et dit un truc faux.
En lisant la phrase suivante, on voit qu’il
ne sait plus très bien ce qu’il fait puisqu’il
RÉPÈTE l’idée selon laquelle la démocratie
représentative serait oxymorique.
Pas besoin de le dire 100 fois, on a compris
!
Ensuite, il continue de dire des choses inutiles.
À quoi bon préciser ICI que le débat démocratie
directe versus démocratie représentative
a opposé Rousseau et Sieyès au XVIIIe siècle
?
Est-ce que ça fait avancer la résolution
du problème intellectuel ?
Bien sûr que non.
Cette information a éventuellement sa place
dans le développement — et encore, ça
ne sert pas à montrer grand chose. C’est
plutôt une phrase qu’on trouverait dans
un manuel d’histoire des idées politiques.
Et puis, sur le fond, je ne sais pas si on
peut vraiment parler d’un « débat » entre
Rousseau et Sieyès, parce que Sieyès s’est
appuyé sur la pensée de Rousseau, et parce
que Rousseau a admis qu’on mette en place
une démocratie représentative SI on l’encadre
strictement.
Bref, Arthur essaie d’en faire trop, et
du coup ça devient trop compliqué.
D’ailleurs, la dernière phrase est complètement
ratée :
« C’est aussi celui qui oppose aujourd’hui
une partie de la population française, qui
ne se sent plus représentée. »
1er problème : une opposition oppose… 2
opposants ! À qui ou à quoi est-elle donc
opposée cette « partie de la population
française » ?
2nd problème : cette « partie de la population
française » ne dit pas que la démocratie
est forcément directe ; elle n’est pas
contre l’idée de représentation ; ce qui
ne lui va pas, c’est qu’elle « ne se
SENT plus représentée » ! Elle ne veut
pas faire les lois, elle veut qu’on la représente
correctement.
Là, Arthur confond donc 2 idées : le caractère
antidémocratique de la représentation, et
l’EFFECTIVITÉ de la représentation.
Bref, la fin de ce paragraphe est vraiment
ratée.
Arthur ne s’est pas concentré sur l’enjeu
de la définition des termes du sujet ; il
a voulu faire plein de choses en même temps,
et il a essayé de manipuler des idées compliquées.
Or, il fallait et il SUFFISAIT de définir
le concept de démocratie.
Retenez la chose suivante : pour BIEN faire,
vous devez faire UNE SEULE CHOSE par paragraphe,
et vous devez la faire SIMPLEMENT.
Rappelez-vous la phrase de Tim Ferriss :« Complexity
fails. ».
Allez, c’est bon pour ce paragraphe. Je
passe au suivant.
Ouh là, ce paragraphe est super long…
Le paragraphe précédent servait à définir
les termes du sujet, donc celui-ci sert probablement
à problématiser le sujet, c’est-à-dire
à découvrir le problème intellectuel à
résoudre dans la dissertation.
Mais bon… Arthur a dérapé dans le paragraphe
précédent, donc celui-ci ne sera peut-être
pas très rigoureux non plus...
Allez, je commence à le lire.
« Jusqu’alors légitime, parce que stable,
la démocratie semble aujourd’hui remise
en cause. »
Ça, c’est le point de départ de la réflexion
d’Arthur : il semble qu’aujourd’hui,
la légitimité de la démocratie ne soit
plus indiscutable.
Sur le plan de la méthodo, c’est exactement
ce qu’il faut faire : il faut commencer
le paragraphe de problématisation par le
point de départ de votre réflexion, c’est-à-dire
l’idée simple et évidente, contenue DANS
l’énoncé, qui stimule la réflexion.
Sur le fond, l’idée paraît juste : la
démocratie, française notamment, semble
en crise.
Au niveau de la forme, c’est simple et clair.
Après, je n’aurais pas parlé de légitimité
ou de stabilité ; je me serais contenté
d’écrire « La démocratie semble aujourd’hui
remise en cause. ».
Ensuite, je ne comprends pas ce qu’Arthur
essaie de faire dans les 2 phrases suivantes.
Il vient d’exposer le point de départ de
sa réflexion, et là il m’explique que
la démocratie française est à la fois représentative
et directe.
Puis dans la 4ème phrase du paragraphe, il
dit que c’est la représentation qui pose
problème aujourd’hui.
Et la 5ème phrase ajoute que la démocratie
française moderne, ce sont aussi les droits
et libertés fondamentaux.
Je m’arrête là parce que ça part dans
tous les sens.
Je récapitule ce que fait Arthur en 5 phrases
: il expose le point de départ de sa réflexion
; il précise que la démocratie française
est à la fois représentative et directe
(grâce à l’alibi du référendum) ; il
dit que c’est la représentation qui pose
problème aujourd’hui ; et enfin, il ajoute
que la démocratie française moderne, ce
sont aussi les droits et libertés fondamentaux.
Bon, vous voyez le problème : c’est super
prise de tête !
Comme dans le paragraphe précédent, Arthur
se disperse et perd de vue l’ENJEU du paragraphe.
C’était pourtant simple : il a bien posé
le point de départ de sa réflexion, donc
il suffisait de l’expliquer dans les phrases
suivantes !
« La démocratie semble aujourd’hui remise
en cause. » : je suis d’accord, mais il
faut justifier un peu cette affirmation — et
c’est à ça que doit servir le début de
ce paragraphe.
Pour me convaincre que « La démocratie semble
aujourd’hui remise en cause. », Arthur
aurait pu évoquer différentes choses : les
taux d’abstention aux élections, la baisse
du nombre de militants dans les partis politiques,
la défiance des Français envers le personnel
politique révélée dans les sondages, le
mouvement des gilets jaunes, etc.
Mais au lieu de ça, il s’emmêle les pinceaux.
Et ça l’amène à commettre des erreurs
d’expression.
Relisez la 5ème phrase de ce paragraphe :
« Alors même qu’au-delà de la faculté
donnée au peuple de choisir ses représentants,
ceux-ci sont également titulaires de droits
et libertés fondamentaux — aussi bien consacrés
par des textes que protégés par des juridictions.
»
Vous voyez le problème ?
« Ceux-ci », c’est qui ? Les représentants
? Le peuple ? Mais « le peuple » c’est
un nom commun singulier !?
Arthur voulait dire que LES CITOYENS FRANÇAIS
sont également titulaires de droits et libertés
fondamentaux.
Comme dans le paragraphe précédent, la complexité
du fond l’a entraîné à commettre des
erreurs de forme.
Je continue.
Dans les 4 phrases suivantes, Arthur revient
au problème de la représentation. Il répète
que la population ne se sent pas représentée
et il explique que ce sentiment entraîne
la remise en cause du système de la représentation
lui-même — et pas seulement de la personne
des représentants.
Pour le dire plus simplement : les Français
ne se sentent plus représentés, donc ils
vont jusqu’à penser que le système est
pourri — ils ne pensent pas seulement que
leurs représentants sont pourris, ils pensent
que le système politique n’est pas bon.
Avec ces 4 phrases, Arthur PRÉCISE le point
de départ de sa réflexion : il précise
LA NATURE de la remise en cause qui affecte
la démocratie française.
En termes de méthodo, c’est bon, parce
que c’est l’explication du point de départ
de la réflexion.
Sur le fond, ça paraît pertinent, mais il
faudra illustrer ces idées pour convaincre
le lecteur.
Sur la forme, c’est plutôt efficace. Je
comprends le propos facilement, donc c’est
clair. J’aime bien la 2ème phrase de ce
passage : comme elle est plus courte, elle
dynamise la lecture ; et puis le conditionnel
modère l’affirmation — c’est un choix
intelligent parce que le sujet est quand même
controversé.
Bon, ces 4 phrases ne sont pas si mal. Moi
je les aurais écrites directement après
la présentation du point de départ de la
réflexion, la 1ère phrase du paragraphe.
C’est-à-dire que j’aurais procédé en
3 temps : 1° présentation du point de départ
de la réflexion ; 2° précision du point
de départ de la réflexion (les 4 phrases
que je viens d’analyser) ; et enfin 3°
illustration pour convaincre le lecteur.
Justement, l’illustration, c’est ce que
fait Arthur dans les 2 phrases suivantes : il
évoque le mouvement des gilets jaunes (qui
avait commencé 6 mois avant l’épreuve),
et il précise intelligemment que le problème
est plus complexe que ce que croient les gilets
jaunes — bah oui c’est une dissertation
pour devenir haut fonctionnaire quand même
!
La 1ère phrase est claire, même s’il n’était
pas nécessaire de donner la date PRÉCISE
de la naissance de la Ve République.
La 2nde phrase est moins claire :
« Mais il ne doit pas couvrir, à cause des
formes radicales de contestation qui peuvent
en surgir, la réalité d’une complexité
bien plus profonde que celle des débordements
et qui renvoie à la question du contrat social
lui-même. »
Non, en fait, elle est trop compliquée. Arthur
répète le mot « contestation » et utilise
une fois de plus le verbe « renvoyer » — verbe
que je trouve trop vague, comme je l’ai
déjà dit.
Moi j’aurais écrit :
« Cependant, la radicalité de ce mouvement
ne doit pas dissimuler la profonde complexité
du problème, qui est liée à la question
même du contrat social. »
Bon, voilà tout pour ce long paragraphe.
Pour le coup, il aurait dû être plus court
: les phrases 2 à 5 ne servent à rien ; la
précision du point de départ de la réflexion
aurait pu être plus rapide ; et je trouve
que l’illustration de ce point de départ
est insuffisante.
Encore une fois, la bonne démarche ça aurait
été 1° de poser le point de départ (comme
il l’a fait) ; 2° de le préciser en 2-3
phrases ; et 3° d’illustrer avec des exemples,
de donner des preuves.
Allez, je passe au paragraphe suivant.
Là, Arthur fait en 2 phrases ce que je recommande
de faire en une seule question : présenter
le problème intellectuel à résoudre dans
la dissertation.
Dans la méthodologie de la dissertation,
ça s’appelle « la problématique ».
Je lis :
« Il faut alors s’interroger sur les raisons
pour lesquelles la démocratie est aujourd’hui
l’objet de controverses, alors qu’il s’agit
du modèle de société choisi il y a plus
de deux siècles. Mais se pencher sur ces
raisons implique inéluctablement de s’interroger
sur la capacité des Français, qu’ils soient
représentés ou représentants, à repenser
ensemble ce que peut et doit être la démocratie
— et donc leur capacité à « faire société
». »
Bon, moi j’impose à mes élèves d’exprimer
le problème intellectuel de la dissertation
sous la forme d’une unique question, mais
c’est possible de le faire avec 1 ou 2 phrases
déclaratives… SI c’est très clair.
Vous le trouvez clair, ce paragraphe ?
Bien sûr que non, il n’est pas clair !
C’est quoi LE problème intellectuel à
résoudre ?!
Eh bien en fait il y a deux problèmes dans
le paragraphe là : les raisons des controverses
actuelles sur la démocratie ; la capacité
des Français à repenser la démocratie.
Sur le fond, ces problèmes sont trop vagues.
Arthur a fourni des précisions dans les paragraphes
précédents, donc il faut qu’il s’en
serve ! Il l’a dit lui-même : le problème
porte précisément sur la représentation.
Et puis il y a des choses inutiles dans ces
2 phrases : il n’est pas nécessaire de
répéter que la démocratie est « le modèle
de société choisi il y a plus de deux siècles
» ; il est inutile de préciser que l’implication
est inéluctable et que les Français sont
des représentés ou des représentants ; il
n’est pas non plus bien utile, à ce stade,
de préciser que la capacité à repenser
la démocratie améliorera la la capacité
à « faire société ».
Voici comment je réécrirais ce passage :
« Il faut d’abord réfléchir aux raisons
pour lesquelles la démocratie est aujourd’hui
l’objet de controverses. Cette réflexion
demande ensuite d’interroger la capacité
des Français à repenser ensemble leur modèle
de société. »
On voit bien, avec cette version plus claire,
à quel point le second problème est vague
: « interroger la capacité des Français
à repenser ensemble leur modèle de société
» ?!
Ouah, je me demande comment on va s’y prendre
!
Non, on ne voit pas du tout le problème intellectuel
de cette dissertation, DONC la problématique
est nulle.
Étant donné les éléments de problématisation
que j’ai lus dans les paragraphes précédents,
je formulerais la problématique de la manière
suivante :
« La représentation étouffe-t-elle vraiment
la démocratie ? »
Cette formulation est certes provocante, mais
c’est pour stimuler la réflexion. Et puis
tout de même, je modère cette hypothèse
avec l’adverbe « vraiment » — donc je
ne suis pas en train de suggérer que les
gilets jaunes ont raison (c’est même plutôt
le contraire).
En conclusion, ce paragraphe censé présenter
la problématique n’est pas bon : c’est
trop vague, trop brouillon, et surtout on
n’arrive pas à saisir la problématique.
Allez, je passe au 5ème et dernier paragraphe
de l’introduction.
Alors, ce paragraphe c’est évidemment l’annonce
de plan (il y a le numéro des grandes parties
entre parenthèses).
Je lis :
« Dans un premier temps, il conviendra d’admettre
que la démocratie, même sous sa forme représentative,
est un modèle légitime qu’il convient
de conserver. Et ce, bien qu’elle fasse
l’objet de contestations. Dans un second
temps, il faudra s’appesantir sur les dérives
de telles contestations. En effet, des voix
s’élèvent pour que la démocratie représentative
soit abandonnée au profit d’une démocratie
directe. Pourtant, la renouveler, lui donner
un second souffle, apparaît peut-être plus
sérieux. »
Je simplifie pour vous le propos de ce plan
: il faut conserver la démocratie malgré
les contestations ; il est plus sérieux de
faire ÉVOLUER la démocratie représentative
plutôt que d’essayer la démocratie directe.
C’est un plan « ENA » en 2 fois 2 parties
: grand I) A., grand I) B., grand II) A. et
grand II) B. avec deux arguments dans chaque
sous-partie.
Alors, avant d’entrer dans des considérations
techniques sur la méthodologie de la dissertation,
je veux dire un mot à propos du fond.
Là, Arthur prend clairement parti : il dit
que les contestations « dérivent » et que
la bonne solution, la solution la plus « sérieuse
», c’est de renouveler le modèle existant.
J’imagine deux types de remarques. Je pense
que certains d’entre vous doivent se dire
: « Eh mais il prend parti, il ne devrait
pas ! » ; et puis d’autres, parmi vous,
se disent peut-être que le propos est trop
conservateur, trop sévère avec les contestations.
Si vous avez pensé une de ces deux choses,
alors vous manquez de pragmatisme.
Rappelez-vous qu’Arthur écrit une dissertation
POUR DEVENIR HAUT FONCTIONNAIRE, c’est-à-dire
pour travailler DANS LE SYSTÈME EXISTANT,
DANS CELUI QUI EST CONTESTÉ en tant que démocratie
représentative.
Pour être plus précis, il veut devenir UN
AGENT du système, de la démocratie française
actuelle, et c’est un agent de cette démocratie
— le correcteur — qui va juger son travail.
Je ne dis pas que la démocratie française
actuelle est un mauvais système, je ne dis
pas qu’elle est un bon système ; je dis
qu’il faut être PRAGMATIQUE.
Vous voulez devenir haut fonctionnaire ? Alors
adoptez, au moins le temps du concours, le
logiciel de pensée des hauts fonctionnaires.
Ne faites pas l’éloge des gilets jaunes
; ne dites pas que l’État français est
probablement la démocratie occidentale la
plus corrompue ; ne critiquez pas l’inefficacité
de la bureaucratie — restez dans le cadre
du discours dominant au sein de l’administration.
Et c’est la même chose si vous passez d’autres
concours. Vous dissertez pour intégrer une
école de commerce ? Ne faites pas une critique
radicale du capitalisme, ne suggérez pas
qu’il faut vendre son âme pour s’enrichir.
Dans son annonce de plan, qui est sa réponse
au problème posé, Arthur fait preuve d’intelligence
stratégique : il montre au correcteur qu’il
pense déjà comme lui, avec le recul et le
cadre de pensée d’un haut fonctionnaire.
Oui, le système est contesté, mais les contestataires
sont dans l’excès — ils ne mesurent pas
la complexité de la question. La meilleure
solution, ce n’est pas la révolution ; c’est
la réforme, c’est de corriger l’existant.
En termes de conformité idéologique, c’est
ce qu’il faut faire.
Mais cette dimension mise à part, je trouve
le plan et l’annonce de plan mauvais.
Le premier défaut, c’est l’ordre des
idées.
Je vais simplifier les idées du plan d’Arthur.
1ère idée : la démocratie est un modèle
légitime à conserver.
2ème idée : la démocratie vit actuellement
une crise de confiance.
3ème idée : la démocratie est contestée
radicalement.
4ème idée : il faut renouveler la démocratie.
Cet ordre n’est pas bon parce qu’il ne
range pas les idées de la plus évidente
à la moins évidente.
Petit rappel de méthodologie : la progression
de la dissertation doit simuler la progression
de la réflexion, donc il faut forcément
aller du plus évident — les idées qu’on
trouve immédiatement — au moins évident
— les idées qu’on trouve au bout d’un
certain temps de réflexion.
En l’occurrence, ça n’a pas de sens de
commencer directement en posant qu’il faut
conserver le modèle actuel de démocratie
— c’est donner immédiatement la solution
au problème. Du coup, ça n’a pas non plus
de sens d’enchaîner avec le constat de
la crise de confiance — il fallait plutôt
commencer par ça, puisque c’est ce qu’il
y a de plus évident — c’est un diagnostic
largement admis dans l’opinion publique.
Si je schématise le plan d’Arthur, ça
donne : défense de la démocratie - constat
de la crise - critique de la contestation
- défense de la réforme.
Là, on réalise que c’est surtout la 1ère
partie qui pose problème : comment passer
logiquement de la défense de la démocratie
au constat de la crise ?
En revanche, le passage du constat de la crise
à la critique de la contestation est naturel,
lui : la démocratie française vit actuellement
une crise, MAIS la contestation est excessive.
Le passage à la 4ème et dernière partie
fonctionne également : la contestation est
excessive, C’EST POURQUOI la réforme est
la meilleure solution.
Mais bon… si j’ai eu besoin de simplifier
les idées dans un 1er temps, puis de les
SCHÉMATISER dans un 2nd temps, ça veut bien
dire qu’il y a un problème d’expression.
Pour les 2 premières phrases, c’est surtout
la forme qui pêche : le verbe « convenir
» ne sert à rien (il fait perdre du temps)
et Arthur le répète ; il est inutile de
préciser « qu’il convient de conserver
» « un modèle légitime » (puisqu’il
est légitime) ; il faut une proposition principale
dans la 2ème phrase.
Pour les 3 dernières phrases, c’est surtout
le fond qui pêche. La phrase « Dans un second
temps, il faudra s’appesantir sur les dérives
de telles contestations. » — cette phrase
résume mal le propos du grand II). En effet,
la 1ère sous-partie ne parle pas de « dérive
», et la 2nde sous-partie parle au contraire
des solutions.
Concernant les idées, je distingue mal le
I.B. (« bien qu’elle fasse l’objet de
contestations. ») et le II (« il faudra
s’appesantir sur les contestations »). Arthur
va parler des contestations dans le grand
I) B., du coup je me demande : pourquoi en
reparler dans le grand II) ?
Sinon, je pense que le verbe pronominal « s’appesantir
» n’est pas le bon choix, parce qu’il
veut dire développer un sujet avec excès
ou insistance — les verbes « étudier » ou
« analyser » étaient plus justes. Je ne
suis pas fan non plus de la voix passive.
Enfin, parmi les qualités de cette annonce
de plan, il faut souligner l’effort fait
pour fluidifier le passage avec des mots de
liaison.
Voici comment je reformulerais l’annonce
de plan d’Arthur (je ne change pas les idées,
mais uniquement la formulation) :
« La démocratie est un modèle légitime,
quoiqu’elle fasse l’objet de contestations.
Seulement, celles-ci accouchent du projet
radical de l’abandon de la représentation,
c’est pourquoi un renouvellement du modèle
français semble nécessaire. »
C’est déjà plus clair, mais la faiblesse
des idées se ressent encore dans la forme.
Je vais donc vous dire le plan que j’aurais
fait pour traiter ce sujet.
Alors, ma problématique c’était : « La
représentation étouffe-t-elle vraiment la
démocratie ? ».
J’aurais répondu à cette question de la
manière suivante :
« La démocratie française semble vivre
une crise (I.A.). En effet, la dimension démocratique
du système représentatif serait illusoire,
à en croire la contestation (I.B.). Si cette
critique paraît excessive eu égard au succès
du modèle français (II.A.), elle invite
cependant à le renouveler dans un sens plus
démocratique (II.B.). »
Voilà voilà, j’en ai terminé avec l’introduction
de cette dissertation.
Je vais maintenant regarder la conclusion.
Arthur a rédigé un seul paragraphe de conclusion
— ça c’est bien.
En termes de taille, c’est suffisant (4
longues phrases), mais disons que c’est
la limite basse pour une dissertation de 12
pages.
Les 3 premières phrases résument le propos
de la dissertation, et la 4ème est une ouverture.
Alors, je l’ai déjà dit dans plusieurs
vidéos : n’essayez pas d’écrire une
ouverture, ce n’est pas un effort rentable.
L’exercice de la dissertation est suffisamment
difficile comme ça.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, regardez ma
vidéo sur la conclusion.
En l’occurrence, c’est plutôt réussi,
mais Arthur aurait pu consacrer les ressources
intellectuelles et le temps qu’il a investis
pour trouver et rédiger cette ouverture — il
aurait pu les consacrer à l’amélioration
de son introduction.
Alors, je sais que les correcteurs regardent
la conclusion rapidement, mais je vais quand
même la lire phrase par phrase, parce que
c’est intéressant.
1ère phrase :
« Deux cent trente ans après le duel « Sieyès
contre Rousseau », la démocratie et sa nature
font encore débat dans la société contemporaine
— en France comme ailleurs ; et particulièrement
à l’échelle de l’Union européenne.
»
C’est plutôt une bonne phrase pour commencer
la conclusion, mais j’ai déjà dit ce qu’il
faut penser du « duel « Sieyès contre Rousseau
» » — moi j’aurais simplement fait référence
à l’accroche (ça aurait créé un bel
effet, d’en parler à la fois au tout début
et à la toute fin de la dissertation).
Sinon, la phrase est claire.
Petit détail : les guillemets anglais.
2ème phrase :
« Légitime et contestée, celle-ci est aussi
menacée par des formes radicales aujourd’hui
hautement visibles — en fluo. »
Sur la forme, phrase plus courte (17 mots)
que la précédente (qui faisait 35 mots)
: c’est une bonne chose pour le rythme.
Elle est très claire.
Sur le fond, elle résume une grande idée
du développement : la démocratie est contestée
bien qu’elle soit légitime — d’accord.
Après, je trouve que la référence aux gilets
jaunes est de trop. Arthur en a déjà parlé
dans l’introduction, là ça commence à
ressembler à une obsession. Un haut fonctionnaire
doit manifester le détachement qui sied à
la défense de l’intérêt général.
Après, si on lit bien à la suite les 2 premières
phrases de cette conclusion, on se rend compte
qu’Arthur a commis une erreur d’expression.
Le pronom démonstratif « celle-ci » désigne
« la démocratie », mais le mot est trop
éloigné pour qu’on comprenne bien. Normalement,
« celle-ci » désigne « l’Union européenne
». Moi, j’aurais écrit : « [...] LE MODÈLE
FRANÇAIS est aussi menacé... ». J’aurais
également pu répéter le nom commun « démocratie
», parce que les répétitions sont utiles
lorsqu’elles permettent d’éviter l’ambiguïté.
L’expression d’Arthur est globalement
efficace, mais il y a tout de même des erreurs.
3ème phrase :
« Renouveler la démocratie apparaît alors
comme un impératif, autant que de s’étonner
qu’une partie de la population se contente
de dénoncer sans participer. »
La construction est un peu compliquée : il
faut renouveler la démocratie, ET il faut
tout autant s’étonner que ceux qui dénoncent
ne participent pas.
Il y a 2 idées dans cette phrase. Moi, j’aurais
inversé leur ordre, et je les aurais opposées
— je trouve que c’est plus simple.
Ça pourrait donner : « S’il faut s’étonner
qu’une partie de la population se contente
de dénoncer sans participer, cette critique
invite toutefois à renouveler la démocratie.
»
Après, la phrase d’Arthur est globalement
claire.
4ème et dernière phrase :
« Comme aime à le dire l’écrivain et
aventurier Sylvain Tesson, dans son ouvrage
Bérézina, « la France est un paradis peuplé
de gens qui se croient en enfer. » ».
Alors, il y a plusieurs choses à dire.
Premièrement, « aimer à » signifie prendre
plaisir à quelque chose, ce qui présuppose
une répétition. Par exemple, j’aime à
corriger des copies de concours — je peux
le dire parce que je l’ai déjà fait et
parce que je compte le refaire à l’avenir.
Ici, il n’y a pas de répétition, puisque
c’est une citation tirée d’un bouquin.
Ensuite, inutile de préciser que Sylvain
Tesson est écrivain et aventurier, parce
que le correcteur le sait. Vous écrivez POUR
VOTRE LECTEUR. Du coup, il était tout autant
inutile de préciser que Bérézina est un
« ouvrage ». Il suffisait d’écrire : « Comme
l’écrit Sylvain Tesson dans Bérézina,
« la France est un paradis peuplé de gens
qui se croient en enfer. ». Et puis il faut
des guillemets français.
Sur le fond, la citation arrive à point nommé
: Arthur vient de relativiser la légitimité
de la contestation, et il termine en disant
grosso modo « On est quand même bien en
France ». Pourquoi pas, mais cet optimisme
me paraît excessif : bien sûr que tout n’est
pas noir en France ; bien sûr que les contestataires
ont intérêt à noircir le tableau — mais
de là à finir la dissertation en disant
que la France est « un paradis »…
C’est certes une ouverture simple et efficace
; c’est une bonne punchline, mais ça peut
donner l’impression que le candidat abandonne
l’objectivité qu’on attend d’un haut
fonctionnaire mû par le service de l’intérêt
général.
Moi j’aurais plutôt relativisé les choses
en rappelant que la France est un pays révolutionnaire,
avec une vie politique historiquement agitée.
Enfin, moi je n’aurais pas fait d’ouverture.
Alors,
je sais que c’était long
— mais l’introduction elle-même était
longue,
et il y avait beaucoup de choses à dire.
Et puis c’est un sujet intéressant.
Qu’est-ce que je pense,
en synthèse,
de l’introduction
et de la conclusion d’Arthur ?
Les trois principaux défauts de l’introduction,
ce sont :
tout d’abord,
la confusion des enjeux :
au lieu de se concentrer sur
UN SEUL et unique enjeu
par paragraphe,
Arthur s’emmêle les pinceaux,
parce qu’il veut trop en faire,
et probablement parce qu’il veut montrer
qu’il a beaucoup de connaissances sur la
démocratie.
Deuxième principal défaut de l’introduction
:
la problématisation est ratée.
Arthur n’explique pas clairement
comment il en arrive au problème intellectuel
qu’il va résoudre dans la dissertation,
et puis je n’ai pas non plus réussi à
identifier
instantanément
et facilement
le problème en question.
Troisième principal défaut de l’introduction
:
la définition des termes
n’est pas efficace.
J’en ai déjà parlé :
il suffisait de donner l’étymologie
du mot « démocratie »,
puis d’opposer l’idéal
et ses applications concrètes,
ce qui permettait d’arriver à la différence
entre la démocratie directe,
et la démocratie représentative.
Voilà pour les trois principaux défauts.
Après,
il y a aussi des imprécisions,
des répétitions,
quelques erreurs d’expression
— mais rien de grave.
Les trois principales qualités,
maintenant.
Tout d’abord,
j’ai bien aimé le paragraphe d’accroche
:
je le trouve efficace.
Ensuite,
le style est efficace,
et je le trouve même plutôt dynamique.
C’est un bon point
parce que ça rend la lecture moins pénible.
Troisième principale qualité :
l’effort de structuration
de l’introduction.
Alors,
je mentionne cette qualité en troisième
parce qu’elle est quand même GÂCHÉE
par la confusion des enjeux
à l’intérieur des paragraphes.
Voilà,
en conclusion,
je suis déçu :
je me suis pris la tête plusieurs fois
en lisant cette introduction,
DONC elle manque de clarté.
Quant à la conclusion de la dissertation,
elle « fait le job ».
Elle est plutôt courte
et elle dit que la France est un paradis
— mais bon,
ce n’est pas grave.
Alors,
maintenant que j’ai lu attentivement l’introduction
et la conclusion
de la dissertation d’Arthur,
je peux situer plus précisément la copie
dans une fourchette de notes.
À mes yeux,
le propos est trop confus
pour mériter plus de 14.
Mais je ne peux pas imaginer mettre moins
de 10,
ce serait trop sévère.
C’est quand même une dissertation bien
rédigée,
avec des qualités réelles.
Donc bon,
à ce stade,
je me dis que je mettrai
entre 10
et 14.
Je vais lire le développement de la dissertation
pour décider de la note finale.
Je vais le lire comme un correcteur de concours
— enfin,
moins superficiellement quand même —
je vais surtout lire les introductions
et les conclusions partielles,
les arguments,
et les introductions de référence.
Allez, c’est parti !
Alors, titre du grand I) : « La démocratie
débattue : entre légitimité et contestation
».
Pourquoi pas. Pour une dissertation rédigée
en 5 heures, c’est un titre efficace — on
ne peut pas demander la lune non plus. On
comprend assez bien l’idée du grand I)
: la démocratie est un modèle qui a fait
ses preuves, bien qu’il soit contestée.
Sur la forme, le titre est simple et clair.
En revanche, je trouve que l’annonce des
deux sous-parties est trop compliquée. Pas
besoin de 3 phrases, ni de citer Churchill,
pour présenter le grand I) A. Comme je l’ai
dit à propos de l’introduction, il faut
dire des choses intéressantes AU BON ENDROIT.
Même reproche pour la présentation du grand
I) B. : mieux vaut se concentrer sur une seule
idée — en l’occurrence l’échec de
l’identification représentés-représentants.
Après, cette introduction partielle est plutôt
efficace, mais le problème est que la méthode
n’est probablement pas réplicable. C’est
la question que j’ai posée à Arthur : serait-il
vraiment capable de gérer cette complexité
de discours pour disserter sur un sujet difficile,
qui demande un effort de réflexion supérieur
? Je n’en suis pas certain.
Sur le plan du style, c’est clair, et les
phrases courtes dynamisent l’expression.
Attention : il y a encore une erreur de pronom.
Quel est le nom que remplace ce « elle » : « forme
représentative » ? « partie » ? « démocratie
» ? Ici, il fallait répéter le bon nom.
Pour écrire clairement, c’est simple : il
faut supprimer l’ambiguïté ; le lecteur
ne doit pas pouvoir hésiter.
Je continue.
Titre du A) : « La légitimité de la démocratie
: un modèle viable. »
Sur le fond, c’est pertinent : la démocratie
est un modèle viable parce qu’elle a passé
l’épreuve du temps (même si on pourrait
répondre que 2 siècles, ce n’est pas non
plus l’éternité à l’échelle de l’espèce
humaine).
Sur le plan de l’expression, on comprend,
mais j’aurais plutôt écrit :
« La légitimité de la démocratie : sa
viabilité ».
Ensuite, Arthur introduit la sous-partie.
Ça fait peut-être beaucoup d’introductions
partielles, mais c’est une bonne chose sur
le plan de la méthodologie, parce que ces
passages permettent d’accompagner le correcteur,
qui est le lecteur, dans le raisonnement.
Le problème, avec cette introduction partielle,
c’est qu’une fois de plus, Arthur complique
les choses. Plutôt que de m’accompagner
dans son raisonnement, il me fournit de nouvelles
connaissances et il répète certaines idées
: l’introduction de la démocratie dans
l’histoire politique française ; l’impossibilité
de la démocratie directe ; le consensus sur
la stabilité du régime démocratique.
C’est trop long et trop compliqué. À quoi
bon préciser ici, par exemple, que la monarchie
est « une tradition aussi française qu’européenne
» ? Une fois de plus, la complexité entraîne
Arthur à commettre des erreurs : les révolutionnaires
ne sont pas « les successeurs » des Lumières,
parce que les révolutionnaires sont des hommes,
tandis que les Lumières sont un mouvement
culturel. Et je pourrais encore souligner
d’autres défauts.
Pour introduire cette sous-partie, il suffisait
de se concentrer sur une seule idée : le
modèle démocratique a passé l’épreuve
du temps.
Après, c’est toujours efficace sur le plan
du style.
Allez, je regarde le tout premier paragraphe
du développement de cette dissertation.
1ère phrase :
« En premier lieu, la démocratie est le
régime que la France a adopté en 1789. »
Sur le fond, cet argument n’est pas bon.
Le fait que la France ait adopté le régime
démocratique en 1789 ne montre pas que ce
régime est viable — ça ne contribue donc
pas à résoudre le problème intellectuel.
L’idée pertinente, à mon avis, c’est
plutôt que la démocratie a remplacé un
régime qui N’ÉTAIT PLUS viable — la
monarchie.
Donc Arthur vise à côté dès le début
de l’argumentation. Il me donne l’impression
de préparer un déballage de connaissances.
En revanche, la rédaction est efficace : la
phrase est courte et claire.
Dans les 5 phrases suivantes, il explique
que les révolutionnaires ont hésité entre
les deux conceptions, directe ou représentative,
de la démocratie.
Dans les 4 suivantes, il explique que la conception
représentative a été retenu pour des raisons
non pas idéologiques, mais pratiques : il
y a trop de citoyens dans un grand État,
et puis les gens n’ont pas beaucoup de temps
à consacrer à la politique.
C’est en réalité la dernière phrase du
paragraphe qui fournit l’argument, même
si elle cible mal l’idée.
Cette idée, c’est : la démocratie directe
semble impossible à mettre en place dans
un grand État. Du coup, par élimination,
c’est la démocratie représentative qui
est viable, et donc légitime.
Que dire d’autre à propos de ce 1er paragraphe
?
Ça se lit facilement, c’est fluide — notamment
grâce aux mots de liaison.
Arthur rappelle une fois de plus le « débat
» entre Rousseau et Sieyès — soit.
Il oublie de souligner la référence (De
la démocratie en Amérique) et il précise
inutilement que c’est un « ouvrage ». Il
ne développe pas assez cette référence
: une seule phrase, c’est vraiment trop
peu.
Ce qu’il fallait faire, c’est : présenter
l’argument (la démocratie directe semble
impossible à mettre en place dans un grand
État) ; l’expliquer en quelques phrases
; et enfin évoquer De la démocratie en Amérique
en quelques phrases pour donner plus de crédit
à l’argument.
Enfin, je remarque aussi quelques détails
: le style d’Arthur est parfois un peu journalistique
(il écrit des phrases sans proposition principale)
; il utilise encore des guillemets anglais.
En conclusion, ce paragraphe est mauvais sur
le plan de l’argumentation, et l’organisation
du propos est maladroite.
Je passe au paragraphe suivant.
« En second lieu, la démocratie est considérée,
ou au moins peut l’être,
comme un régime relativement stable. »
1ère chose : Arthur structure le grand I)
A. très simplement avec les liens logiques
d’énumération « En premier lieu » et
« En second lieu ». Ce n’est pas de la
grande littérature, mais c’est efficace
; c’est facile à lire.
Sur le fond, cet argument est pertinent : l’idée
de la stabilité de la démocratie montre
bien que c’est un modèle viable, ce qui
est l’idée du grand I) A.
Arthur présente cet argument avec modération
: la démocratie « peut être considérée
[...] » « [...] comme un régime RELATIVEMENT
stable ». Alors, c’est bien, mais l’expression
est un peu maladroite — en particulier la
locution « ou au moins peut l’être ». Moi
j’aurais écrit plus simplement : « En
second lieu, le régime démocratique jouit
d’une relative stabilité ». Remarquez
aussi que le passage à la voix active améliore
instantanément l’expression écrite.
Après, la phrase d’Arthur est quand même
claire — c’est moi qui suis un maniaque
du style.
Dans les 2 phrases suivantes, il cadre historiquement
sa démonstration : il dit « regardons les
3 dernières républiques ».
Dans les phrases 4, 5, et 6, il explique la
stabilité du modèle français par son caractère
composite. L’idée, derrière, c’est que
c’est un modèle mieux adapté à la réalité
— c’est pour ça qu’il serait durable.
La référence aux Principes du gouvernement
représentatif de Bernard Manin, un ouvrage
de référence sur le thème de la démocratie
— cette référence est trop allusive.
Dans les phrases 7 à 10, il introduit une
seconde référence, Les 60 ans de la Constitution,
et il s’en sert pour apporter du crédit
à son argument. Mieux vaut mobiliser une
seule référence par paragraphe du développement,
mais là, c’est bien sur le plan de la méthodo,
parce qu’Arthur mobilise une référence
pertinente et parce qu’il prend soin de
la développer.
La 11ème et dernière phrase du paragraphe
en rappelle l’idée directrice. C’est
bien, mais le style est journalistique (à
mon goût).
L’expression écrite est toujours efficace
dans ce paragraphe. Les phrases s’enchaînent
plutôt bien grâce aux mots de liaison. Arthur
commet une grosse faute d’orthographe : « le
souligneNT » puisque l’ouvrage a deux auteurs.
Il y a encore de petites imperfections, mais
le correcteur n’y fera pas attention.
Mis à part la mobilisation de 2 références,
je trouve que c’est un paragraphe efficace
sur le plan de l’argumentation. Arthur présente
une idée précise qui va dans le sens de
celle de la sous-partie, puis il l’explique
clairement.
Il termine la sous-partie avec une transition
:
« Néanmoins, la démocratie est aujourd’hui
l’objet de sérieuses contestations : le
débat qui opposait Sieyès et Rousseau est
relancé avec force. »
C’est simple et ça tease le grand I) B.
Le rappel du débat Sieyès - Rousseau est
un peu irritant, mais bon, la transition est
efficace. Arthur accompagne le correcteur
jusqu’à la prochaine étape de son raisonnement
: c’est bien.
Allez, je passe à la sous-partie suivante.
Titre de ce grand I) B. : « La démocratie
contestée : la crise de la confiance. »
C’est court et très clair : ça me plaît.
Introduction partielle de ce grand I.B. :
« Aujourd’hui, une partie de la population
française ne se sent plus représentée : elle
n’a plus confiance en ses représentants.
La démocratie dans sa forme représentative
est alors contestée. Et à cet égard, ce
sentiment est exacerbé par les nouveaux moyens
de diffusion de l’information, tels que
les réseaux sociaux, lesquels participent
à renforcer la crise de confiance envers
les décideurs publics. »
Les 2 premières phrases répètent une énième
fois des idées qu’on connaît depuis l’introduction,
et la 3ème introduit ce qui sera — j’imagine
— l’argument du second paragraphe de la
sous-partie. Honnêtement, c’est trop compliqué.
C’est très bien d’accompagner le correcteur,
mais il faut le faire simplement. L’objectif,
c’est uniquement de lui fournir des points
de repère ; il est inutile de répéter 15
fois les mêmes idées ou d’introduire une
première fois les arguments avant les paragraphes
du développement.
Pour introduire ce grand I) B., moi je me
bornerais à dire que la technologie amplifie
un sentiment de la conscience collective.
Ce sera ensuite aux paragraphes de préciser
cette idée générale.
Sinon, le style est toujours efficace dans
ce passage. Je trouve juste que la locution
« Et à cet égard » crée un lien artificiel
et plutôt maladroit.
Allez, je passe au 1er paragraphe de cette
sous-partie.
Alors, 1ère phrase : « Tout d’abord, la
démocratie est aujourd’hui l’objet de
contestations d’une partie de la population.
»
Est-ce que vous voyez le problème avec cette
idée ?
Le problème, c’est qu’elle au même niveau
de généralité que celle de la sous-partie.
Le grand I) B., c’est que la démocratie
est contestée, et le 1er argument de ce I)
B. c’est… que la démocratie est contestée.
Donc ça ne va pas : il fallait une idée
plus précise. J’ajoute qu’Arthur a répété
je ne sais combien de fois depuis l’introduction
l’idée que la démocratie est contestée.
Rien que dans cette sous-partie, on la retrouve
dans le titre, dans l’introduction partielle
et dans le 1er argument !
En fait, la véritable idée de l’argument
arrive à la phrase suivante : « Un profond
sentiment d’injustice anime certains citoyens
etc. ». Pourquoi la démocratie française
est-elle contestée ? Parce que certains citoyens
ont le sentiment qu’elle est injuste. C’est
donc bien cette idée, l’argument du paragraphe.
Les phrases 2 et 3 disent que le sentiment
d’injustice vise les professionnels de la
politique.
La suite du paragraphe explique la dérive
de ce sentiment.
Les phrases 4, 5 et 6 disent qu’il crée
un climat de défiance qui empêchent les
Français de prendre leur destin en main.
Arthur mobilise une référence classique
dans les concours de la fonction publique,
mais il l’introduit mal (le verbe arrive
trop tard) ; il ne la développe pas assez
(2 phrases, c’est trop peu) ; et il commet
une GROSSE faute d’orthographe : encore
une fois, il y a 2 auteurs, donc c’est « dénonceNT
».
Ensuite, les phrases 7, 8, 9 et 10 défendent
l’idée que la dérive du sentiment d’injustice
culmine dans le complotisme. Arthur mobilise
une 2nde référence — vous savez ce que
j’en pense — mais il la développe mieux
que la 1ère.
Enfin, la 11ème et dernière phrase de ce
paragraphe opère la transition vers l’idée
du paragraphe suivant : les réseaux sociaux
amplifient la dérive du sentiment d’injustice.
Alors, au global, ce paragraphe est moyennement
réussi. L’argument n’est pas présenté
clairement dans la 1ère phrase — le début
du paragraphe est raté — mais l’idée
est pertinente. Je trouve aussi que l’idée
de la corruption du sentiment d’injustice
en défiance généralisée d’abord, puis
en complotisme — je trouve que cette idée
est efficace pour développer l’argument.
Autre défaut : Arthur mobilise encore 2 références.
Après, l’expression écrite est efficace
dans le paragraphe (notamment grâce aux liens
logiques).
Globalement, c’est dommage : les idées
sont intéressantes ; le paragraphe est plutôt
cohérent ; mais l’argumentation manque
de rigueur.
Je passe au paragraphe suivant.
1ère phrase : « Ensuite, et en effet, le
sentiment de distance entre représentants
et représentés est exacerbé par l’utilisation
irréfléchie des réseaux sociaux. »
Sur le fond, Arthur se répète, puisqu’il
a voulu annoncer cet argument à la fin du
paragraphe précédent : il a déjà dit que
les réseaux sociaux amplifient la contestation
; maintenant il dit que les réseaux sociaux
amplifient le sentiment d’une distance entre
les représentés et les représentants — on
n’a pas gagné grand chose en termes de
sens.
Il y a trop de redites dans cette dissertation
parce que le déploiement de l’argumentation
n’est pas assez rigoureux. Là, par exemple,
il suffisait de présenter l’idée de l’argument
UNE SEULE FOIS au début du 2nd paragraphe.
Sur le fond, toujours, je trouve que parler
d’une utilisation « irréfléchie » des
réseaux sociaux est à la fois vague et un
peu condescendant. C’est quoi une utilisation
« irréfléchie » ? Moi, je me serais contenté
de dire que les réseaux sociaux amplifient
le sentiment de défiance des représentés
à l’égard des représentants.
Sur la forme, la locution « Et en effet » n’est
pas terrible : elle n’apporte pas grand
chose et elle nuit à la fluidité de la lecture.
La structure « Tout d’abord… Ensuite...
» est certes basique, mais c’est suffisant
pour une sous-partie subdivisée en 2 arguments.
Enfin, toujours sur la forme, j’aurais également
tourné la phrase à la voix active : « L’utilisation
irréfléchie des réseaux sociaux exacerbe
etc. ».
La 2ème phrase répète une énième fois
que c’est le principe de la représentation
qui est visé par les critiques.
Les phrases 3, 4 et 5 disent que les réseaux
sociaux peuvent créer une pression démocratique
dans les pays autoritaires. Là, je ne vois
pas à quoi ça sert de consacrer 3 phrases
et 1 référence à l’idée CONTRAIRE de
celle qu’Arthur est censée défendre. Il
aurait pu mentionner cet effet en passant,
mais là il en parle trop. Je pense qu’il
a commis cette erreur parce qu’il n’avait
pas de matière pour crédibiliser son argument.
En outre, une fois de plus, il ne développe
pas assez la référence.
Les phrases 6, 7 et 8 reviennent à l’argument
du paragraphe et le défendent avec l’exemple
des fake news. C’est beaucoup trop court
: c’est tout au long du paragraphe qu’il
fallait expliquer et PROUVER l’idée selon
laquelle les réseaux sociaux creusent le
fossée de confiance entre les représentés
et les représentants.
La phrase 9 répète — comme la 2ème phrase
— l’idée que c’est le principe de la
représentation qui est visé par les critiques.
D’ailleurs les deux phrases sont identiques
à 1 mot près !
Sur le plan du style, l’expression est efficace,
et fluide en particulier, dans ce paragraphe.
Les phrases sont bien connectées explicitement
les unes aux autres. L’alternance entre
phrase longue et phrase courte crée du dynamisme.
En revanche, je déplore l’usage de la voix
passive et les guillemets anglais.
On arrive à la conclusion partielle du grand
I).
Dans la 1ère phrase, Arthur répète une
énième fois que la démocratie EST CONTESTÉE…
Si le correcteur ne l’a pas compris, c’est
qu’il est amnésique…
Arthur reprend sa référence à Churchill
: pourquoi pas, ça crée une impression de
cohérence.
L’idée qui est intéressante pour la transition
arrive à la 2ème phrase : la diversité
et la conflictualité des opinions est normale
en démocratie — c’est la radicalité
de la contestation qui pose problème. Cette
conclusion partielle est efficace, parce qu’elle
amène bien la prochaine grande idée.
Alors, j’en ai terminé avec la grande partie.
Qu’est-ce que je peux en dire ?
Pour faire synthétique,
je vais énumérer les trois principaux défauts,
et les trois principales qualités
de cette première grande partie.
Le premier principal défaut,
c’est la pertinence de l’argumentation.
Normalement,
CHAQUE paragraphe
doit commencer par une idée précise
qui sert à PROUVER
l’idée plus générale de la partie.
Or,
ça c’est souvent raté.
Le deuxième principal défaut,
c’est la cohérence des paragraphes.
Je vous l’ai dit,
la bonne démarche pour rédiger un paragraphe,
c’est de présenter une idée,
de la développer,
puis de l’illustrer.
Or,
Arthur ne procède pas comme ça :
c’est confus ;
il part dans une direction,
dans une autre ;
puis il revient.
Dans le second paragraphe du B),
il défend même l’idée INVERSE
de celle de l’argument.
Le TROISIÈME principal défaut
de cette première grande partie,
c’est plus généralement
le manque de rigueur de l’argumentation.
Arthur MÉLANGE les idées PRÉCISES
avec les idées GÉNÉRALES,
les connaissances avec les arguments,
les introductions partielles avec les arguments
— bref,
en termes de méthodo,
c’est trop confus.
Maintenant,
quelles sont les trois principales QUALITÉS
de cette première grande partie ?
La première,
à mes yeux,
c’est l’expression :
c’est quand même vraiment CLAIR,
et fluide
— ça c’est un TRÈS BON POINT.
La deuxième principale qualité,
c’est l’impression de PERTINENCE
qui se dégage :
mine de rien,
en répétant SYSTÉMATIQUEMENT
les mêmes idées,
Arthur me donne l’impression
qu’il est
ABSOLUMENT FOCALISÉ sur le sujet,
qu’il traite le sujet
ET RIEN QUE le sujet.
Enfin,
la troisième principale qualité de ce grand
Un,
c’est la qualité des connaissances.
Arthur connaît bien son cours
— et peut-être trop bien,
d’ailleurs,
parce qu’il a du mal à s’en détacher
pour se focaliser
sur la qualité de l’argumentation.
À mes yeux,
il veut trop en faire,
il fournit trop d’informations
— alors que l’enjeu est
de SÉLECTIONNER
les informations pertinentes
pour CONVAINCRE le lecteur.
À ce stade de ma correction,
je suis déçu :
je trouve que c’est trop confus
— même s’il y a bien sûr des qualités.
En termes de notation,
je penche plutôt vers le DIX.
Mais bon,
je vais peut-être encore changer d’avis.
Allez,
on se plonge dans la SECONDE grande partie
de cette dissertation !
Alors, regardons un peu le titre du grand
II) :
« La démocratie en péril : de la dérive
à l’apaisement ».
C’est très clair, mais il y a un problème
sur le fond : l’idée de péril ne synthétise
pas le passage de la dérive à l’apaisement.
D’ailleurs, ce passage ne s’est pas produit,
et la dissertation d’Arthur ne fait que
préconiser l’apaisement pour remédier
à la radicalisation de la contestation. La
locution « de la dérive à l’apaisement
» est donc trompeuse. Moi j’écrirais plutôt
: « La démocratie en péril : la nécessité
de l’apaisement ».
Regardons maintenant l’annonce des sous-parties.
Elle est un peu moins compliquée que celle
du grand I), mais c’est encore trop compliqué
à mon goût.
La structure de la 1ère phrase est maladroite
:
« Les contestations tenant à la représentation
sont aujourd’hui telles que d’aucuns revendiquent
la nécessité de passer à une démocratie
directe. »
On peut dire bien plus simplement que « la
contestation de la représentation aboutit
à la défense de la démocratie directe ».
Mais je pense que le plus simple était encore
de fusionner les 2 premières phrases, ce
qui donnerait quelque chose comme : « La
défense de la démocratie directe occulte
le véritable enjeu, l’amélioration de
la représentativité. »
La 3ème phrase, celle qui introduit le B),
est, elle, claire. Je la tournerais juste
à la voix active : « Les citoyens semblent
attendre un renouvellement... ».
Les 2ème et 3ème phrases de ce paragraphe
sont bien claires, la 1ère l’est un peu
moins, comme je l’ai dit.
Sur le fond, il y a bien sûr des partis pris
idéologiques. La revendication de la démocratie
directe ne constitue pas en elle-même une
dérive, mais un haut fonctionnaire d’une
démocratie représentative le pense probablement.
Et puis c’est maladroit de dire qu’on
doit renouveler la démocratie pour apaiser
la population — on doit surtout la renouveler
pour l’améliorer, et si l’amélioration
est réelle les citoyens seront satisfaits.
Mais bon ce sont des détails. Ça montre
que c’est un sujet un peu touchy par les
temps qui courent, et qu’il fallait faire
preuve d’une certaine habileté politique.
De ce point de vue, Arthur a été plutôt
bon : il a dit au correcteur des choses qu’il
est prêt à entendre.
Regardons maintenant le titre du A) : « La
dérive : la démocratie évincée ».
Bon, c’est très court et très clair, mais
je trouve que l’adjectif « évincée » est
excessif. La démocratie est bien contestée,
mais elle n’a pas été vaincue ; le système
représentatif français est toujours en place,
il fonctionne toujours. J’aurais plutôt
écrit « la démocratie MENACÉE ». Et encore...
Ensuite, Arthur introduit la sous-partie en
2 phrases.
Je trouve qu’il aurait pu s’en passer,
parce que ces 2 phrases n’apportent rien.
La 1ère répète l’idée de la RADICALITÉ
de la contestation, et la 2nde répète l’idée
selon laquelle la contestation radicale est
à côté du vrai problème, qui est l’effectivité
de la représentation, et non pas la démocratie
elle-même.
J’ajoute qu’il y a une maladresse d’expression
dans chaque phrase : « qu’elles soient
idéologiques VOIRE physiques » (il fallait
écrire « OU physiques ») ; et « mais le
cadre dans lequel il y en a à résoudre », cette
proposition n’est pas claire (encore moins
si on la lit rapidement).
Donc bon, l’introduction partielle n’est
pas terrible.
Allez, je regarde le 1er paragraphe du grand
II).
1ère phrase : « D’une part, la démocratie
telle qu’elle existe aujourd’hui sous
sa forme représentative en France est ébranlée
par une partie de la population qui désire
la voir directe. »
Donc Arthur commence avec l’argument selon
lequel la revendication de la démocratie
directe ébranle le système français actuel.
C’est un bon argument, mais la forme n’est
pas bonne. Déjà, la phrase est trop longue
(27 mots) pour commencer le paragraphe. C’est
parce que la construction est trop lourde
: « la démocratie TELLE QU’ELLE EXISTE
AUJOURD’HUI SOUS SA FORME REPRÉSENTATIVE
EN FRANCE » ; et puis « UNE PARTIE DE LA
POPULATION QUI DÉSIRE LA VOIR DIRECTE ». Je
trouve aussi que la présentation de l’idée
manque de modération.
On peut écrire bien plus simplement : « D’une
part, la revendication de la démocratie directe
semble ébranler le système français actuel.
».
Ce n’est pas utile de préciser « qu’une
partie de la population » veut la démocratie
directe, parce que ça reste vague.
Enfin, commencer par le connecteur logique
« d’une part… », c’est pas mal : ça
structure clairement le propos, et puis ça
change.
Les phrases 2 à 5 ne constituent pas un développement
pertinent, parce qu’elles montrent que le
système démocratique actuel est déjà en
partie direct. Ça ne prouve pas que la revendication
de la démocratie directe ébranle le système
français actuel. C’est le même problème
de rigueur de l’argumentation que dans le
grand I).
J’ajoute que la 2ème phrase relève d’un
style journalistique : il faut une proposition
principale.
Les phrases 6, 7, 8 et 9 disent que l’ignorance
des contestataires — ils ignorent les opportunités
de démocratie directe du système actuel
— leur ignorance favorise le populisme.
Ce développement est pertinent par rapport
à l’argument, parce que le populisme ébranle
le système politique actuel.
Cependant, encore une fois, Arthur ne développe
pas assez la référence. Et je trouve aussi
que l’interprétation du populisme qu’il
présente n’est pas très subtile : les
figures charismatiques veulent gagner des
voix et attiser les conflits…
En outre, Arthur donne encore dans le style
journalistique en écrivant deux phrases nominales
à la suite : « Pour récupérer des voix.
», « Pour attiser les conflits. ».
La dernière phrase répète l’idée selon
laquelle la contestation radicale passe à
côté du vrai problème.
En conclusion, ce paragraphe présente les
mêmes défauts que ceux du grand I) : l’argumentation
manque de rigueur, le propos de cohérence
; la référence est insuffisamment développée.
L’expression est toujours globalement efficace,
et particulièrement fluide grâce aux mots
de liaison — mais la formulation de l’argument
est ratée.
Je passe au paragraphe suivant.
1ère phrase : « D’autre part, évincer
la démocratie telle que celle appliquée
en France, c’est-à-dire représentative,
au profit d’une démocratie directe, ne
peut être opportun et constitue peut-être
même un leurre. »
Comme celle du paragraphe précédent, cette
1ère phrase est trop compliquée. La formulation
est lourde : « telle que celle appliquée
en France, c’est-à-dire représentative
» ; « ne peut être opportun et constitue
peut-être même un leurre ». Elle manque
aussi de modération — et cela d’autant
plus que le sujet est controversé.
Sur le fond, c’est trop vague : qu’est-ce
que ça veut dire « ne peut être opportun
et constitue peut-être même un leurre » ?
En fait, quel est le problème avec la revendication
de la démocratie directe ? Eh bien, Arthur
l’a dit à la fin du paragraphe précédent
: les contestataires défendent un projet
radical alors qu’il y a déjà beaucoup
à espérer du renouvellement de la démocratie
représentative. Si on la cible bien, l’idée
c’est que le projet du passage à la démocratie
directe est trop risqué.
Voici comment, moi, je formulerais l’argument
:
« D’autre part, le projet du passage à
la démocratie directe paraît risqué. »
La 2ème phrase explique que c’est un problème
de personnes, pas de système.
La 3ème affirme que le système actuel est
une conquête à préserver.
La 4ème dit qu’il faut tolérer les critiques
du système français, mais pas aveuglément.
Avec la 5ème phrase, on a droit à un point
Godwin : en substance, si on est trop soft
avec les adversaires de la démocratie représentative,
on déroule le tapis rouge à Hitler. Là,
Arthur consacre UNE SEULE ET UNIQUE phrase
à la référence qu’il mobilise : c’est
littéralement du name dropping. En plus,
ce n’est pas super pertinent, comme le révèle
le lien logique « À cet égard », qui est
superficiel. Mais bon, on lit « Hitler », donc
l’esprit critique se met en veille.
La 6ème et dernière phrase répète que
le projet du passage à la démocratie directe
est trop radical. 2 petites remarques d’expression
: 1° on utilise le pronom « d’aucuns » lorsqu’il
est vraiment difficile d’identifier les
agents, et plutôt en début de phrase — là
moi je parlerais des contestataires ; 2nde
petite remarque : il faut écrire « réfléchir
À la façon » parce que l’objet de la
réflexion est plutôt précis — on réfléchit
À un problème, on réfléchit SUR sa vie
(mais moi je préfère dire « réfléchir
À » dans tous les cas).
En conclusion, ce 2nd paragraphe n’est pas
terrible. Comme dans le premier, l’argumentation
n’est pas claire. Dans celui-ci, la référence
n’est pas du tout développée. Arthur répète
des idées qu’il a déjà évoquées plus
haut dans la dissertation. Enfin, ce paragraphe
est court : 6 phrases, contre jusqu’à 12
phrases dans le grand I). Ce n’est pas une
bonne chose de paraître de moins en moins
inspiré au fur et à mesure que le correcteur
avance dans la copie.
Je regarde la conclusion partielle. Arthur
l’a écrite à l’arrache : elle est plus
courte que les conclusions partielles précédentes,
et le propos est maladroit. La succession
des adjectifs (« renversée, évincée, ou
conspuée ») est désordonnée, et puis un
système politique ne peut pas être conspué,
car « conspuer » veut dire huer publiquement
une personne ou un groupe de personnes.
Quant à la 2nde phrase (« C’est alors
parler d’apaisement. »), elle n’a pas
de sens. L’idée précise, c’est que le
renouvellement de la démocratie française
aura un effet apaisant sur les tensions sociales,
ou bien qu’on a intérêt à renouveler
le système actuel DANS LE BUT D’APAISER
les tensions sociales.
Mais bon, je pense qu’Arthur a écrit dans
l’urgence.
Je passe à la partie B).
Voici le titre : « L’apaisement : la démocratie
renouvelée ».
Je ne sais pas pourquoi Arthur veut à tout
prix parler d’apaisement. L’apaisement,
ce n’est pas ce dont il s’agit ; l’apaisement,
c’est l’effet hypothétique du renouvellement
du système politique français.
Moi j’aurais écrit comme titre : « Le
nécessaire renouvellement de la démocratie
».
Regardons maintenant l’introduction partielle
du grand II) B.
Alors, Arthur présente 2 solutions. Solution
n°1 : le personnel politique doit regagner
la confiance des Français. Solution n°2
: les citoyens doivent réfléchir à leur
propre responsabilité politique.
L’idée de la 1ère solution est claire,
mais la formulation est maladroite : « une
responsabilité CONSISTANT À PERMETTRE un
regain... ». Il suffisait d’écrire : « D’un
côté, les décideurs publics doivent regagner
la confiance des citoyens ».
Quant à la 2nde solution, c’est l’inverse
: la formulation est plutôt claire, mais
l’idée est vague. Qu’est-ce que ça veut
dire concrètement « s’interroger sur son
rôle dans la Cité » ? Au moins, on peut
mesurer l’application de la 1ère solution
: il suffira de faire les mêmes sondages
avant et après.
Sinon, la mise en balance des 2 solutions
avec la construction « D’un côté… de
l’autre... » est efficace.
Voici comment, moi, je formulerais cette introduction
partielle :
« D’un côté, les représentants doivent
regagner la confiance des représentés. De
l’autre, les citoyens doivent aussi réfléchir
à leur propre responsabilité dans le vivre-ensemble.
».
Allez, je regarde le 1er paragraphe de cette
partie.
1ère phrase : « Premièrement, la démocratie
pourra peut-être être mieux acceptée et
considérée à sa juste valeur par les Français
si leurs représentants poursuivent leurs
efforts tendant à réinstaurer la confiance.
»
Bon, Arthur répète — et encore moins clairement
— la même idée que trois lignes plus haut
: les représentants doivent regagner la confiance
des Français. C’est bien d’accompagner
le lecteur dans le raisonnement, mais là,
une fois de plus, c’est trop.
Pour éviter cette redite, moi j’aurais
simplifié l’introduction partielle de cette
partie en disant que le renouvellement de
la démocratie française est à la fois de
la responsabilité des représentants et des
représentés. Et ensuite, j’aurais précisé
l’idée dans la 1ère phrase du 1er paragraphe
en disant que la responsabilité des représentants,
c’est de regagner la confiance des citoyens.
Sur la forme, maintenant, Arthur introduit
son argument avec le connecteur logique d’énumération
« Premièrement » : c’est basique, mais
simple et efficace.
Mais la phrase est trop longue (28 mots),
et sa construction trop lourde. Inutile d’ajouter
« considérée à sa juste valeur » après
« mieux acceptée » — c’est presque
une répétition d’idée. Et puis « Leurs
efforts tendant à réinstaurer la confiance
», c’est lourd.
Pour améliorer la formulation de cette phrase,
je la passerais à la voix active : « Premièrement,
les Français reconnaîtront davantage la
valeur de leur démocratie si leurs représentants
regagnent leur confiance. »
Dans les phrases 2 et 3, Arthur introduit
une 1ère référence. Elle est très pertinente,
MAIS elle arrive trop tôt, et il ne la développe
pas assez (il n’y consacre que 2 phrases).
Je vous rappelle qu’en dissertation, il
faut expliquer l’argument sur quelques phrases
avant de mobiliser une connaissance.
La 4ème phrase dit que la solution de Luc
Rouban est limitée.
Les phrases 5 et 6 disent que l’État français
s’attelle déjà au problème de la représentativité.
Dans la 7ème phrase, Arthur introduit une
seconde référence en mode name dropping.
La 8ème et dernière phrase du paragraphe
opère la transition vers l’idée du paragraphe
suivant : le citoyen a LUI AUSSI une responsabilité.
Erreur d’expression : CHAQUE citoyen ne
peut pas s’interroger « COLLECTIVEMENT
» — il faut plutôt écrire que « les
citoyens doivent s’interroger à la fois
chacun personnellement et collectivement ».
Bon, que dire de ce paragraphe ? Je n’en
pense pas beaucoup de bien. Tout d’abord,
la présentation de l’argument est ratée,
et puis Arthur n’explique pas son argument.
Autre défaut : il mobilise 2 références
de manière très allusive.
Sur le plan de l’expression écrite, ça
reste efficace, comme dans les parties précédentes
de la dissertation. À part peut-être la
1ère phrase, c’est facile à lire et fluide.
Les phrases sont bien connectées les unes
aux autres.
Je passe au paragraphe suivant.
1ère phrase : « Deuxièmement, les responsabilités
ne peuvent pas uniquement peser sur les décideurs
publics. »
Alors, c’est très clair sur la forme. La
phrase est courte (12 mots) et l’adverbe
« deuxièmement » rend la structure de la
sous-partie transparente. Autre qualité : l’expression
de l’idée est plutôt modérée (« les
responsabilités NE PEUVENT PAS UNIQUEMENT
peser... »).
Sur le fond, je trouve que l’idée de l’argument
n’est pas assez précise. Là, il faut dire
ce que doivent FAIRE les citoyens pour renouveler
la démocratie. Pour rester synthétique,
on peut dire qu’ils doivent participer davantage
à la vie politique.
La 2ème phrase développe l’argument en
disant que la démocratie est précisément
faite pour cela, pour que les citoyens participent
— ce qui, soit dit en passant, s’oppose
à l’idée de la nécessité d’un renouvellement…
Les phrases 3 à 5 montrent qu’il y a des
éléments qui vont dans le bon sens.
La 6ème phrase évoque la piste de rendre
le vote obligatoire.
Puis Arthur fait du name dropping : Thucydide
a dit qu’un citoyen apathique est inutile.
Enfin, il termine le paragraphe sur une note
positive : en réalité, les citoyens prennent
de plus en plus conscience de leur propre
responsabilité. Et encore un petit coup de
name dropping pour finir, cette fois-ci en
oubliant de souligner la référence.
Bon, que dire de ce paragraphe ?
Pour une fois, la 1ère phrase me plaît sur
la forme — mais pas sur le fond. Ensuite,
l’argumentation est confuse, comme dans
le reste de la dissertation. Je pense qu’Arthur
pouvait simplement commencer en disant que
les citoyens doivent s’impliquer davantage
dans la vie politique ; dire ensuite qu’il
y a de bons signes de cette évolution ; et
prolonger en disant qu’on peut aller encore
plus loin — pour appuyer ce dernier point,
il aurait alors mobilisé et développé sa
2nde référence, Radicaliser la démocratie
de Dominique Rousseau, dans le dernier tiers
du paragraphe.
Concernant la forme, l’expression écrite
est toujours efficace, malgré des imperfections.
C’est toujours fluide grâce aux connecteurs
logiques. Attention, encore une fois, aux
guillemets anglais.
Alors,
est-ce que le grand deux
m’a fait changer d’avis ?
Eh bien non.
Comme je pouvais m’y attendre,
j’ai retrouvé les défauts du grand un
:
l’argumentation manque de rigueur,
les paragraphes de cohérence,
et le propos est globalement
trop confus à mon goût.
J’ajoute que dans ce grand deux,
Arthur verse à plusieurs reprises
dans le name dropping.
De l’autre côté,
la copie est facile à lire,
et elle mêle des connaissances
de différentes natures :
la philosophie politique,
le droit administratif,
l’actualité
etc.
— mais bon,
c’est ce qu’on attend d’un élève
qui a préparé SÉRIEUSEMENT
le concours de l’ENM.
Voilà pour le grand deux.
Il est maintenant temps
de donner une note à la copie.
Alors,
je vais faire comme je fais
pour corriger les copies
des élèves de ma formation :
je vais vous donner
par ordre d’importance DÉCROISSANT
les trois principaux défauts de la copie,
puis les trois principales qualités ;
et puis je donnerai une note.
C’est parti !
Alors,
le plus gros défaut de la copie,
c’est l’OBSCURITÉ
de la problématisation.
Je l’ai dit en commentant l’introduction
:
on ne saisit pas facilement
quel est PRÉCISÉMENT
le problème intellectuel
que va résoudre la dissertation.
Je vous l’ai déjà dit :
c’est bien plus clair
— et bien plus simple,
en termes d’exécution —
de poser
UNE SEULE ET UNIQUE question
à la fin de l’introduction,
puis d’y répondre dans l’annonce de plan.
Deuxième plus gros défaut de la copie :
le manque de rigueur
de l’argumentation.
Je veux dire plusieurs choses par là :
les idées des arguments ne sont pas toujours
les bonnes,
parce qu’il arrive à Arthur de confondre
les idées GÉNÉRALES
et les idées PRÉCISES ;
parfois l’argument n’apparaît pas au
début du paragraphe,
mais à l’intérieur ;
parfois il n’est pas formulé clairement
;
enfin,
le déroulement de l’argumentation dans
le paragraphe
est souvent confus :
Arthur a du mal à se FOCALISER sur l’idée
directrice,
à l’expliquer
et à l’illustrer.
Enfin,
troisième plus gros défaut de la copie :
la mobilisation des connaissances.
Oui,
Arthur a de BONNES connaissances,
mais il ne les mobilise pas assez efficacement.
Dans l’introduction, déjà,
plusieurs passages confinent à la récitation.
Ensuite,
Arthur utilise parfois des connaissances
dans les introductions
et les conclusions partielles,
alors que ces parties servent uniquement
à ACCOMPAGNER le correcteur
dans le raisonnement.
Enfin,
Arthur ne développe PAS ASSEZ les références,
et il se contente même d’allusions
vers la fin du développement.
Globalement,
je trouve qu’il a voulu trop en faire.
Il connaissait bien son cours ;
il a voulu le montrer,
et il l’a fait AU DÉTRIMENT
de l’argumentation.
Comme je le dis souvent
aux élèves qui me contactent,
UNE SEULE idée
et UNE SEULE référence
par paragraphe
suffisent LARGEMENT
pour écrire une dissertation exceptionnelle.
Voici pour les principaux défauts,
je passe maintenant
aux trois principales QUALITÉS
de cette copie.
La première qualité de cette dissertation,
c’est l’expression écrite.
J’ai trouvé des maladresses,
mais globalement c’était facile à lire
:
je n’ai jamais eu à faire un effort pour
comprendre
ce qu’Arthur voulait dire
— notamment parce qu’il utilise
beaucoup de liens logiques,
ce qui fluidifie le propos.
Deuxième principale qualité de cette copie
:
l’impression de PERTINENCE
qui s’en dégage.
J’en ai déjà parlé en conclusion du grand
un,
mais je le répète
parce que c’est important :
Arthur donne bien l’impression
qu’il est FOCALISÉ sur le sujet.
Pour produire cette impression,
il soigne ses introductions
et conclusions partielles,
ses transitions ;
et il répète INLASSABLEMENT
les idées et les termes clés
— il les répète même trop je trouve,
mais bon,
je ne me suis pas dit une seule seconde
qu’il était hors sujet !
Après,
ce n’est pas qu’une histoire d’impression,
parce que la plupart des idées d’Arthur
touchent JUSTE,
même s’il les présente de manière confuse.
Enfin,
troisième qualité principale de la copie
:
la conformité idéologique.
Alors,
à mes yeux,
dans les circonstances de ce concours,
c’est bien une qualité.
Je l’ai déjà dit,
c’est une preuve de PRAGMATISME.
Arthur ne résout pas un problème de maths,
il écrit un discours
qui sera corrigé
PAR UN ÊTRE HUMAIN.
Donc s’il veut une bonne note,
il ne doit pas FROISSER
cet être humain.
Il doit donc rester
dans LE BON cadre de pensée.
C’est comme ça :
ça ne veut pas dire
que nous vivons dans une matrice,
que nous sommes conditionnés
— c’est simplement
la nature des sociétés humaines :
elles tirent leur cohésion
d’une certaine dose
de conformité idéologique.
En définitive,
peu importe qu’Arthur pense
OU PAS ce qu’il écrit,
il réalise un exercice
POUR ATTEINDRE un objectif
DONC il dit UNIQUEMENT
des choses que le correcteur
— certainement un haut fonctionnaire,
en l’occurrence —
il lui dit uniquement des choses
qu’un haut fonctionnaire français
est prêt à entendre.
Parfois,
il force un peu le trait,
je trouve,
mais il fait ce qu’il faut
pour s’attirer LA COMPLICITÉ
de son correcteur.
Voilà pour les qualités.
Je résume tout :
d’un côté,
la problématisation est obscure ;
l’argumentation manque de rigueur ;
la mobilisation des références
n’est pas assez efficace ;
de l’autre côté,
LE STYLE, lui,
est efficace ;
le propos produit
une bonne impression de pertinence ;
et enfin,
Arthur dit au correcteur
ce qu’il est prêt à entendre.
Alors maintenant,
quelle note est-ce que je donnerais
à cette copie ?
Déjà,
certainement pas 14 ou 15,
parce que l’argumentation
est trop confuse.
Mais je pense que 10 ou 11
ça serait trop sévère,
étant donné la qualité de l’expression
écrite.
Donc je noterais cette copie
12 sur 20.
Comme je l’ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises,
je suis globalement DÉÇU
de la copie,
parce que c’était un sujet facile
— « la démocratie »,
c’est carrément un thème du programme.
Donc étant donné que les connaissances
ne devaient pas être un problème pour les
candidats,
j’attendais une argumentation synthétique
et rigoureuse.
Or,
celle d’Arthur est confuse.
Voilà,
maintenant que devez-vous retenir
de mon commentaire ?
Le premier enseignement
que vous pouvez en tirer,
c’est que si vous voulez trop en faire,
vous ferez probablement mal.
N’essayez pas d’impressionner le correcteur
avec vos connaissances ;
n’essayez pas de bourrer votre cours
dans votre dissertation.
Non,
pour bien faire,
faites SIMPLE.
Comme je l’ai dit à Arthur,
je ne suis pas sûr qu’il puisse obtenir
une aussi bonne note
sur un sujet plus difficile,
parce que sa méthode est trop compliquée.
DEUXIÈME enseignement
que vous pouvez tirer de mon commentaire :
la clarté du style est SURVALORISÉE.
À contenu comparable,
une dissertation rédigée clairement
gagne trois quatre points
— voire plus !
Je pense d’ailleurs que c’est la raison
principale
pour laquelle Arthur décroche un 15 :
malgré des imperfections,
son expression écrite est claire
tout au long de la copie.
D’ailleurs,
le rapport de jury de 2019
dit qu’il recherche,
je cite :
« un style clair
dénué d’artifices. »
Apprenez donc à écrire clairement,
travaillez votre style :
c’est bien plus rentable
que d’apprendre des milliers de références
par cœur !
TROISIÈME enseignement
que vous pouvez tirer de mon commentaire :
c’est important de bien distinguer
les différents NIVEAUX
de l’argumentation.
Vous devez être capables de classer vos idées
par niveaux de généralité.
En particulier,
les arguments sont des idées PRÉCISES
qui servent à défendre des idées plus générales,
celles d’une grande partie
ou d’une sous-partie du développement.
La dissertation,
ce n’est pas un contrôle de connaissances,
mais un exercice dans lequel
vous devez MANIPULER des idées
afin de résoudre un problème intellectuel.
Voilà pour les trois enseignements à tirer
de cette vidéo :
l’efficacité de la simplicité ;
la valeur de la clarté du style ;
et l’importance
de bien hiérarchiser vos idées.
Voilà,
c’est tout pour aujourd’hui !
Oui,
c’était long,
mais je pense que c’est un moyen efficace
pour progresser rapidement en dissertation.
À ce propos,
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez vous inscrire
à mon cours gratuit de méthodologie.
Le lien doit s’afficher maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
et vous pouvez aussi le trouver
dans la description.
Ce qui a été long,
ce sont aussi la préparation
et la production de cette vidéo.
Elle m’a demandé énormément de travail.
Donc si vous voulez m’aider,
n’hésitez pas à me donner un pouce bleu,
ou à m’encourager dans les commentaires.
Et la meilleure aide que vous puissiez m’apporter,
c’est de partager cette vidéo autour de
vous :
diffusez le lien auprès de vos amis,
des personnes que vous connaissez
qui préparent des concours,
ou tout simplement des épreuves de dissertation.
Bien sûr,
si vous avez des questions,
vous pouvez me les poser dans les commentaires,
et je vous répondrai avec plaisir.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère vraiment que vous avez aimé cette
vidéo,
et qu’elle vous sera utile.
Je suis Romain,
et je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête
pour RÉUSSIR une dissertation.